[Music]
all right everybody in an article
submitted by my best friend of the whole
world Steve Green
com it's going to ruin me cut that all
right we're going to talk about this
he's going to co-host the AKA I don't
know about it he knows everything here
we go okay you're welcome all see day
continuation half a day um so George
Collin's daughter lambas the AI
generated um standup special they made
of him so this is kind of wild right so
yeah dud and you got to hear this
actually and I'm curious about everybody
you guys like Carlin are we fans yes
Carlin one of the greatest of all times
agreed agreed he went to jail for saying
he did isn't that crazy jail for saying
the jail for going on tour saying a lot
of bad words so here we go um it just
bad words this is AI this is Carlin tell
me what you think there's one line of
work that is most threatened by ai1 job
that is most likely to be completely
erased because of artificial
intelligence standup
comedy I know what all the standup
Comics across the globe are saying right
now I'm an artist and my art form is too
creative too nuanced too subtle to be
replicated by a machine no computer
program can tell a fart joke as good as
me this is insan well let's see this is
just off the artificially intelligent
that's AI mhm wow this is all Ai and
this is by the way from Will Sasso
responding to this you might hear some
voices but this that's not part of the
special but this is the clip we got cuz
Anthony pulled it it's crazy like they
even have like the intonation of his
delivery of like which words to
emphasize like what words to put
emotions behind and it it sounds and
feels like him did a human construct
this or AI did everything AI did
everything we'll see wow and they might
be making his point art was in the
middle of a very nasty divorce so she
went to wait let me take it back that's
pretty crazy so he's talking about a
fart right M yeah okay nasty divorce so
she went to her I'm just going to take
back back back okay intelligent head a
fart was in the middle of a very nasty
divorce so she went to her sister's
house and she asked her sister do you
think I'm doing the right thing by
getting divorced and her sister said
he's been holding you back for too long
you have to leave that
ass oh
St look at that there you have it
standup comedy is dead literally I might
be the first standup IC to be brought
back from the dead by AI but I certainly
won't be the Richard prior Joan Rivers
Bill Hicks Robin Williams Dick Gregory
Andy Kaufman mom's mayy Sam Kennison
everybody's coming back and we're all
going to have our own 24hour a day 7day
a week
365 day a year streams comments on
everything that's happening in the world
as it happens AI resurrected standup
comedians are going to be the news
anchors of the next decade which now
that I think of it it means news anchors
are probably out of a job
too some people are going to be against
that some people are always going to
want a real flesh and blood human being
observing the world and telling jokes
about it and I get that I really do but
if you can keep an open mind I think I
can make a case for at least one
comedian we can all agree is better in
AI form Bill
Cosby oh [__] D is that not and it's
good writing too yeah is that not still
better than half of the [__] doing
[__] today that's
crazy like that is AI so how did they
program the Carlin personality they fed
him they fed the computer all the Carlin
[__] that's mind blowing they asked him
to construct stuff that's like that same
way you talk to J Chad TBT which I'm
sure you do all
day 9 A.M to 900 p.m. you're talking to
chat gbt I can't be convinced otherwise
that [__] is mind-blowing
yeah that's crazy have his delivery his
writing Cadence writing style content
even to have a con like the trippy part
the consistency and the style of mic and
where his mouth is in relation to the
mic he he pops it that's so true you
know what I mean like the it's so weird
most people don't don't hear that that's
so true and the way that he um he he's
like he's like yes that's right me and
all your favorite comedians we're coming
back 24/7 365 we're going to be a
podcast you're going to listen to all
all the time and that's exactly how he
talked the dystopian like projection
it's all [__] we're all [__] the way
he analy like his analysis of the world
but then just more like 2024 2025 like
they're feeding him the world and it's
still his brain analyzing it which is
crazy right wow that's terrifying so
yeah so um his daughter Kelly Carin she
is a radio host and she is very uh upset
about this new comedy special which I
encourage every wanted to at least check
out from a humanist perspective just
check it out it's so interesting cuz
it's dope cuz it's crazy yeah it's well
this I haven't seen the whole thing but
this cuz we were like in the middle of
JK block when this came out are they
going to do like Tupac hologram
Resurrection style and AI be good yeah
things suck that'll be songs he never
even made before dude I saw that [__] up
close and personal cuz I knew the people
who did that [__] they invited me over
and they showed me a bunch of holograms
and [__] I like whatever so no I was tup
holog and it was awesome you know why
because Snoop Dog right before that was
like everybody put your [__] blunts
in the air so he made everybody in the
crowd smoke and we was all smoking
[__] joints and stuff and then they
brought out a holog ground while we were
high that was brilliant that's way cool
I was I'm just wondering what the visual
[__] dude I wonder what the visual
is going to be cuz they we've got the
audio part right so then now what's the
visual like so Tupac right you know what
song he's going to do yeah with Carlin
this is so different right you're going
to hear a new thing people want to hear
a new thing but even with Tupac will be
new Tupac songs well yeah I just want to
know what the visual is going to be
though probably be music videos all it's
all audio Carlin had so many records
though that he didn't have visuals for a
lot of his standups right I want to see
a guy talking on a mic that's why I
brought up the Hologram stuff what we
going to do are we going to have a robot
are we going to have a hologram what we
going to do no I think it's going to be
I think it's be George Carlin you turn
on Netflix and it's his new special and
it's George Carlin or Tupac or whoever
on
doing cuz the Deep fake technology is so
crazy now sozy you already seen it in
like TV shows that are like replicating
old presidents and stuff like that with
their voices and then they're using the
lip stuff of like old
footage easier the Breakthrough is that
it's [__] sounds like something he
would say when it previously didn't
exist see and honest to God before this
I thought AI is a joke soul is joke blah
blah blah everything everyone's saying
this is [__] I'm like the as big a
fan as you as they come this is like
like spot on it's really scary
witnessing the first flight you know
when you like like a [__] Kitty Hawk
or whatever see the right brothers and
you're like I don't know what this going
to lead to but it's crazy that people
humans are now off the ground we're out
of the job guys yeah I feel like we're
seeing like the first flight we're like
what the [__] does this even mean for
the future someone's just going to
upload JK news and they're going to just
replicate us and then now it's just
going to keep going on AI Joe is going
to be maybe the easiest thing everyone
ever made but the scariest thing if they
can replicate guys like Carlin we're way
beneath I like to jack off all tell of
the details it's like he's saying like
weather people would be out of a job
because you have [__] Carlin you know
yeah I mean come
on you get you crack Joe in 15
minutes they don't know how to be random
like me but then they can't do subin
they're like how the [__] do you get
this guy what you just hit it with a
hammer just keep hitting it with a
[__] Hammer I do think the uh the
value of something though
at least from a human perspective the
value of something is in its content but
also the
authenticity is equally as important
yeah so kind of like even our old like
with the last to topic we're talking
about to some people yes this could be a
Rolex but if it's not deemed a Rolex it
doesn't have the Rolex stamp to them
it's still not a Rolex so it's the
difference yeah it's the difference
between watching like a Super Bowl live
versus you can watch the exact same
thing tomorrow at a more comfortable
time but people want to tune in live
because it is that right then there are
people trash people like myself like
Nick right who are like I don't care
just give me the discount and give me
the product there's people TR like that
yeah but then all right let's say you're
getting sucked off by the dark night and
then you're just wearing VR goggles to
watch a [__] happen that's not going
to be the same as getting sucked off by
a real person but how do you know have
you done it I think I should Tred yeah I
think you should and there's also people
who are getting that Rolex but don't
know it's fake yeah so in their mind
it's real so maybe it's not really a
replacement thing it's just the Market's
got bigger now there's more and more
options and it's not really fake Rolex
replaces real Rolex or real Rolex who
plays fake Rolex there's just two
markets now and maybe you didn't know
what you didn't know I never got to go
to a Michael Jackson concert so I went
to an impersonators and it was just as
good I don't know about that dude hey
was really good though he's innocent
falling off yeah no his his skin tone
was shifting during the show cuz of
sweat no cuz of sweat but he wrestled a
homeless man and that was cool and he
kind of smelled like the lost and found
a little bit I don't know you know it's
another scary another scary thing to
think of is that like whenever you see
things like this like read the comments
of even just that you'll see all these
opinions about no we got to stop this
this is disgusting blah blah blah we're
I think one generation away from just
nobody cares anymore it's just noral
yeah we're the last people that can stop
it and give a [__] to stop it and once
we're gone that's it everyone's born
into this and it's fine that's what Elon
is probably so against it I think yeah
yeah he hates robots he doesn't want
[__] or he thinks singular is going
to happen Rob to do all of our labor he
doesn't hate it he's just talking about
the symbiosis between but he lets robots
land in [__] Rockets robot drive his
car damn right the fear is that Humanity
may not survive to see the
overcorrection right cuz they'll just AI
the will kill it yeah the like wait you
guys are the problem well the AI will
kill the society which kills itself it's
not the it's not like lasers like we
think it's like the quality of life and
the will to live like what the [__]
happens when that's gone you guys should
watch AI artificial intelligence one of
my favorite movies of all time Joel
osman's yeah he's one of my favorite
Osman wait that's really one of your
favorite movies yeah hands down one of
my favorite movies ever ever is super
old it's like from1 or some [__]
Spielberg movie yeah yeah it's really
it's really dreamy you know Donnie Osman
is is the father of Haley Joel
Osman he that boy was in everything well
you know why now he was like the Wonder
Boy industry
plan